[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 28 janvier voici
les titres de l'actualité locale
il a débarqué la nuit dernière aux
sables d'olonne l'yvelinois louis dutton
boucle le vendée globe à la troisième
place 80 jours 10 heures 25 minutes et
12 secondes de course à la voile autour
du monde pour le rambolitains une belle
performance pour sa troisième
participation nous étions sur place lors
de son arrivée et des étudiants au
domicile des seniors pour des rencontres
de convivialité le dispositif pièces
plus proposé l'été a été redéployée cet
hiver par le département des yvelines
une action que rompre l isolement des
personnes âgées exacerbée en cette
période de crise sanitaire
elle nous parlerons également d'une
initiative similaire à l'association et
des veilleurs qui est proposé à voisins
le bretonneux
et puis la rencontre des lycéens de jean
vilar à plaisir avec l'écrivaine
clémentine meslois elle a été organisée
dans le cadre des leçons de littérature
une opération de la région ile de france
proposés dans les établissements
franciliens retour dans cette édition
également sur j'enfile mes baskets pour
les ânes à une course virtuelle et
solidaire qui a débuté qui va se
poursuivre durant deux semaines c'est à
la fin de ce journal
louis burton a donc terminé le vendée
globe sur la troisième marche du podium
au terme d'un parcours plein de
rebondissements l'yvelinois est arrivé
dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi à
minuit à 45 heure française
retour sur cette performance avec
michael et demi d'euros et bixente mais
rien senti steban
louis burton a achevé cette nuit un peu
après minuit son vendée globe
arrivé en deuxième aux sables d'olonne
derrière charlie dalin il se classe
finalement troisième
après yannick bestaven vainqueurs grâce
aux compensations obtenues pour le
sauvetage de kevin escoffier un tour du
monde en solitaire bouclé en 80 jours 10
heures 25 minutes et 12 secondes
c'est une histoire sur une dizaine
d'années qui s'écrit avec avec une
équipe qui s'écrit avec un partenaire
avec des sponsors est arrivé couper
cette ligne en deuxième place le leur
offrir ça c'est grande joie pour moi une
grande satisfaction et puis
personnellement une grande fierté
ce qu'il a fallu aller la chercher du
début à la fin cette place car tout ne
s'est pas déroulé comme prévu et le
premier jour louis burton est sanctionné
d'une pénalité de cinq heures pour avoir
franchi la ligne de départ de seconde
trop tôt il ne savait pas encore que la
victoire se jouerait dans un mouchoir de
poche
pourtant très bien passé évidemment mais
on va essayer de se rassurer en vue donc
vainqueur à l'échelle 1
les globes c'est pas grand chose
cafouillage dans le décompte entre
j'avais à l'ordinateur et puis
j'entendais à la vhf
mais ce contretemps lui aura permis de
réparer son bateau et être parfaitement
affrété pour passer le cap de bonne
espérance
j'ai cru à l'entrée de l'océan indien en
fait assez tôt dans la course
je me tiraient la bourre avec les
bateaux de tête
ensuite ça a été l'ascenseur émotionnel
tout en bas au fond du trou tout en haut
tout en bas tout en haut tout en bas
depuis le début de l'océan indien
jusqu'à il ya quelques jours encore
affaiblie par de nombreuses avaries sur
sa grande voile louis burton aura même
frôlé l'abandon nous sommes le 20
décembre
le skipper qui n'a pas dormi depuis deux
jours décide de se réfugier à l'abri des
vents forts derrière l'île macquarie un
petit archipel isolé au milieu du
pacifique
il monte sur son mât effectuer des
réparations en bravant sa peur du vide
donc maintenant on va descendre sans se
casser la figure
[Musique]
j'ai lâché et on va lui même pourra tous
s'en suit une remontée qui restera dans
les annales du vendée globe de la 11e à
la première position en franchissant
l'équateur pour remonter vers les sables
d'olonne
c'est une course étonnante le vendée
globe pour ça il faut être capable
d'oublier complètement ses objectifs ses
ambitions sportives et je s'accrocher à
une chose c'est rester en vie rester sur
son bateau et puis et puis terminer un
podium accroché au bout du suspense
puisque son concurrent boris herrmann a
heurté un bateau de pêche quelques
heures avant son arrivée
l'ayant contraint à fortement ralentir
louis burton achève ainsi son deuxième
vendée globe en trois participations
il le boucle en sept jours de moins que
lors de la précédente édition en 2016
bonsoir michael et demi d'euros pour la
rédaction de tv 78,2 vous avez suivi
cette arrivée aux sables d'olonne vous
étiez sur place pendant deux jours et ce
que déjà vous avez pu récupérer malgré
la courte nuit on l'a vu louis burton
qui arrivait dans la nuit aux sables
d'olonne nous avons un grégory je n'ai
dormi que deux trois heures en plus avec
la route donc je suis un petit peu
fatigué je dois vous l'avouer on va vous
laisser après récupérer mais d'abord un
compte et nous c'est une belle émotion
c'est bien quand ils jouent cette
ambiance justement vous étiez au plus
près de l'arrivée vous étiez sur un
bateau pour suivre l'arrivée de louis
burton aux sables d'olonne
comment ça s'est passé on imagine de la
joie qui régnait hier
alors tout d'abord quand remonte sur le
bateau pour aller voir louis burton on
ne sait pas ce qui va se passer un
clairement quitte le port on s'éloigne
on s'éloigne on s'éloigne et là tout
d'un coup on voit une lumière au loin
c'était bill burton il y avait environ
une cinquantaine de bateaux autour de
lui j'ai essayé tant bien que mal de
films et malgré la mère qui était et qui
était un petit peu capricieuse 1 je dois
l'avouer voilà tout simplement c'était
un moment plutôt magique
en tant que journaliste sportif un peu
le revivre d'ailleurs puisque vous aviez
proposé un live sur la page facebook de
tv 60,18 forcément on imagine de la joie
de retrouver sa femme servane escoffier
ses enfants également également
effectivement il ne les avait pas vus
depuis à 80 jours
donc forcément c'était la première chose
qu'ils voulaient faire en arrivant sur
terre il a pu les voir notamment sur mer
juste à vent mais il a pu vraiment les
rejoindre sur sur terre quand ils
arrivent au port
tout de suite il a pris à ses enfants
dans ses bras il a pris a également sa
femme dans ses bras et évidemment avec
nelson son frère aussi qu'ils étaient
ivres l'inra qui a grandi du coup à côté
de rambouillet à la celle des les bordes
avec louis burton
c'était vraiment son son noyau dur c'est
peut-être ce ces personnes là qui lui
ont permis
on l'a vu dans reportage précédemment
que c'était ça a été difficile il faut
il faut l'avouer c'était très difficile
ce vendée globe pour lui burton il a
voulu abandonner le 20 décembre sur les
îles macquarie c'est une petite île
perdue tout temps dans tout en bas de
tout en bas de la nouvelle zélande il ya
voulait abandonner à ce moment là mais
il a eu apparemment un coup de fil de
servane escoffier qui lui à qui la
rebooster
pour terminer ce vendée globe il ya
également eu son frère qui lui a parlé à
ce moment là du coup ces deux personnes
l'ont rebooster et du coup il a fait ce
qu'il a fait derrière c'est à dire une
superbe remontée pour arriver deuxième
sur la ligne d'arrivée aux sables
d'olonne
dans un instant et avec le scénario
incroyable il franchit la ligne à la
deuxième position finalement avec les
compensations il termine troisième
puisque yannick bestaven a terminé le
vendée globe grâce aux compensations à
la première place c'est un scénario
incroyable
jusqu'aux dernières heures de la course
il y avait quatre voire cinq skippers
qui pouvait l'emporter 1 alors nous
enfin au niveau des supporters de louis
burton ainsi je peux le dire celui qui
nous faisait peur c'était plutôt boris
herrmann boris herrmann l'allemand qui
devait normalement privé louis burton du
coup du podium à cause de ces
bonifications il devait arriver
normalement trois heures après leurs
tonnes il devait donc lui passer devant
au classement au classement final
ça aurait été un petit peu dommage que
louis burton ne soit pas sur le podium
après une course pareille finalement
boris herrmann quelques heures avant
percute
ce chalutier au large de la france et du
coup pour issermann abandonne
n'abandonne pas mais abandonne ses
chances en tout cas de podium
louis burton à parler justement en
conférence de presse juste après ils
n'étaient pas contents forcément de
gagner de cette façon là mais bon on
pense qu'il est quand même content
finalement de ce podium petit coup du
sort puisque c'est cet accident qui a
permis à louis burton d'accéder au
podium et on rappelle que lors de sa
première participation en 2012
il avait abandonné suite à un accident
avec un bateau de pêche il avait percuté
également un bateau de pêche des
radiations michael on vous parliez de
cette remontée fantastique après 7
cet art est forcément sur les îles
macquarie où il a réparé réparer son
bateau est ce que pour vous au vu du
scénario cette onzième place aux hymnes
macquarie remonte jusqu'à la première
place au final il termine troisième on
peut dire que c'est la plus belle course
de ce vendée globe la plus belle
performance d'un skipper sur demande et
la performance pas forcément mais je
pense que c'est la plus belle aventure
peut-être de ce vendée globe parce qu'il
faut se rappeler que que louis burton
est parti avec un faux départ un des
sables d'olonne en novembre dernier il
avait dû déjà ce moment là à voir une
pénalité à ce moment-là il pensait que
cinq heures de pénalité
finalement ce n'était pas grand chose à
l'échelle d'un vendée globe finalement
le classement final but donne tort
finalement sur cette phrase il est parti
du coup avec ce faux départ toute la
traversée de l'atlantique
la première traversée de l'atlantique il
a eu des problèmes techniques c'était
très compliqué ensuite si la ce fameux
problème au niveau de son mât ozil
macquarie il répare et ils montrent tout
en haut de son mât maquis et qui est
très impressionnant j'étais juste à côté
de son bateau tout à l'heure un mât qui
était de 13 mètres je crois ainsi si mes
souvenirs sont bons et ensuite la la
remonte à dar vraiment il va y va très
vite il fait peut-être la meilleure
course meilleure seconde partie de
course
il passe de la 11e à la première place
dimanche dernier il était premier en
penser qu'il allait peut-être remporter
la victoire et finalement il a ils
terminent deuxièmes sur ligne d'arrivée
troisième au classement classement final
donc forcément un très beau vendée globe
pour lebron un très beau vendée globe on
imagine des souvenirs plein la tête pour
lui bravo à lui et vous reviendrez sur
cette performance michael lors de
l'émission cette ut sport c'est lundi
prochain sur tv 78 on aura aussi
l'occasion de reparler de cette
performance dans l'émission de talksport
sur tv soit 118 sél eux si on parlait
sport qui est programmé à début février
merci à michael d'avoir états et les
gens qui y dans l'actualité cette
information importante toutes les
agences pôle emploi de france seront
fermés demain vendredi
exceptionnellement cette décision fait
suite au meurtre d'une employée ce jeudi
matin dans une agence de la drôme les
services reste néanmoins accessible par
téléphone au 39 49 et sur le site
internet de pôle emploi
l'été dernier pour répondre à la crise
sanitaire le département des yvelines
avait renforcé son dispositif yvelines
étudiants seniors riès plus pour lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
il a été redéployée cet hiver par la
collectivité explications d'eléonore
sinoquet de célia gars de son gant
depuis décembre et jusqu'à mars le
département des yvelines a remis en
place le dispositif
yes plus service similaire à yvin
étudiants seniors qui avait été créé
pendant la canicule de 2003 ce
dispositif a pour objectif de lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
dans le cadre de
sanitaires le département a décidé
d'aller plus loin me renforcer ce
dispositif est de créer laisse plus donc
si s plus c'est 300 étudiants et
demandeurs d'emploi qui rendent visite
aux personnes âgées à domicile leur
passent des appels de convivialité les
accompagne notamment lors de promenades
ce service est en place dans plus de
trente commune yvelinoise ali mais par
exemple pauline est étudiante en année
de césure a été embauché comme agent de
convivialité
j'aime bien l'idée de partage de
d'apprendre quelque chose des gens de me
sentir utile aussi et c'est vraiment ça
qui m'a donné envie de concrétiser les
choses je deviens vraiment quasiment à
chaque visite on parle de la situation
actuelle qu'est-ce que ça engendre les
conséquences et qu'est ce que ça peut
leur faire c'est donc j'avais même la
maladie yes plus bénéficier à plus de 8
me seniors non dépendons avec la crise
sanitaire le service est apprécié ça me
fait du bien parce que vu que je que je
fais tout seul et puis que j'ai pas j'ai
pas mes frères et soeurs qui viennent je
suis bien conscient d'avoir des jeunes
qui on parle
on va se
on va se promener sa bonne voie ça ne
change beaucoup mais les idées le
dispositif est gratuit pour les
personnes âgées et fait l'objet d'un
financement par le département
coût de l'opération 800000 euros cela
comprend notamment les salaires des 300
étudiants et demandeurs d'emploi à
voisins le bretonneux une association
justement agit depuis plus de 15 ans
pour lutter contre ce sentiment
d'isolement des personnes âgées les
veilleurs en voisin et sa présidente
marie dominique barral est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous la crise sanitaire only
imagine à amplifier ce sentiment
ressenti par les personnes âgées ce
sentiment d'isolement et ce qui l'est
plus exacerbée aujourd'hui ce sentiment
d'isolement
oui bien sûr il est plus acerbe et
surtout que au premier confinement nous
avons été obligés d'arrêter nos mots nos
visites et de passer uniquement des
coups de téléphone ce qui vous imaginez
bien qu'avec des personnes âgées un coup
de téléphone dure cinq dix minutes grand
maximum après c'est fatigant pour elle
où elles n'entendent pas bien donc
la perte était vraiment important par
rapport à une visite mais parce que ces
visites c'est avant tout la discussion
alors dit comme ça ça peut paraître
dérisoire mais pour ces personnes âgées
ça veut dire beaucoup le fait de pouvoir
échanger de continuer à avoir un lien
social ils ont été privés de ce lien
social justement tout à fait
l'association consistant à placer les
bénévoles qui vont visiter les personnes
isolées qui ont été détectés soit par
nous mêmes nos adhérents ou bien les ccs
de voisins-le-bretonneux et nous mettons
en place des visites
nous avons la particularité de pour
éviter des liens trop fort parce que
souvent nous visitons ces personnes sur
du long terme une dizaine d'années pour
certaines nous avons mettons en place
deux bénévoles par personne visitée
d'abord pour se socialiser un peu plus
et puis pour éviter un lien trop fort
qui se crée au fil des années donc une
semaine c'est un bénévole qui a visité
la semaine suivante c'est l'autre et
l'association le but c'est de passer un
moment de convivialité avec les pertes
homme d'une heure et demie à deux heures
par semaine c'est soit la discussion à
bâtons rompus sur tous les sujets qu'ils
souhaitent soit y en a qui préfèrent
jouer qu'on a des fans de scrabble ou de
triomino il y en a qui préfèrent qu'on
leur fasse la lecture parce qu'elles
sont plus en état d'accueillir il y en a
qui veulent sortir se promener enfin
voila c'est très varié mais voilà c'est
l'idée de passer un moment de
convivialité
alors bien sûr en tous sens texte actuel
marie-dominique barral parents pourquoi
c'est important de veiller sur nos
seniors est ce que c'est une forme de
reconnaissance pour pour eux qui nous
ont précédé cette génération qui nous a
pressés oui et puis le constat avait été
fait il ya quinze ans que dans nos
villes nouvelles mais voilà le risque
d'isolement pour elle était encore plus
importante ce qui avait déclenché la
création d'associations c'était qu'on ne
gagne qu à celle d'aden avait retrouvé
une personne décédée après plusieurs
jours dans sa maison et savait vraiment
réveillé un peu les les consciences
voilà comment les identifier vous
justement est ce que ces personnes qui
viennent vers vous justement ce sont
peut-être se sont peut-être vous qui a
faim c'est vous qui allez à eux
justement comment ça se passe en fait le
nom de l'association ces veilleurs en
voisin et donc on a à peu près une
centaine d'adhérents et aux adhérents
leur demande aussi des veilleurs tir de
veiller d'être attentifs dans leur
quartier autour d'eux sur les personnes
isolées qui puisqu'ils peuvent remarquer
et de nous les signaler et nous après
nous faisons la démarche d'aller leur
proposer les visites de nos bénévoles
voilà il publie aussi à travers le ccas
qui peut être contacté pour des
personnes aidées les difficultés pour
ces personnes-là et donc elles nous font
remonter l'information en disant voilà
que deux rallyes visiter telle ou telle
personne et vous pour allier vous
parliez tout à l'heure de l'engagement
de ces bénévoles sollicités en binôme et
fonctionnant en binôme et aussi pour
alterner
ces contacts on imagine l'importance des
bénévoles on peut le dire peut-être que
vous êtes à la recherche de bénévoles si
vous souhaitez passer un appel allez zou
oui effectivement dans le contexte
actuel nous avons beaucoup plus de
demandes parce que les familles
s'inquiètent pour leurs aînés et donc
nous contactent énormément en ce moment
donc on a beaucoup de nouvelles
personnes à visiter
heureusement les choses sont bien faites
en même temps beaucoup de personnes en
ce moment se présentent spontanément
pour être bénévole donc on arrive à peu
près à mais voilà on a toujours besoin
de nouvelles bénévoles mais surtout des
bénévoles qui s'inscrivent dans la durée
c'est pas juste pendant le pendant la
pandémie
et voilà c'est sur le long terme est ce
que les personnes âgées on peut pas le
changer tout ce sont les personnes qui
viennent visiter c'est important qu'ils
aient cette relation confiance qui
s'établissent et donc ça les perturbe
récits ont changé trop souvent donc
recherche vraiment des personnes qui
s'investissent dans la durée nous les
formons nous offrons nous organisons des
formations pour que l'accompagnement se
fasse bien donc les formations à
l'écouté formation sur les mails
d'alzheimer la formation voilà les
limites de l'accompagnement voilà des
termes de formation et nous avons aussi
des groupes de parole pour les bénévoles
avec un psychologue ou il ya un échange
et un partage sur les situations
compliquées ou ou questionnante qu'elle
se rencontrer lors de leur
accompagnement et de psychologues nous
apporte un éclairage et nous aide ici
ainsi à progresser dans notre eau notre
service et si vous souhaitez devenir
bénévole ou souhaitez recevoir la visite
des veilleurs vous pouvez contacter
l'association via les liens qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci marie
dominique barral d'avoir est avec nous
présidente de l'association les
veilleurs en voisin dans l'actualité
politique une tribune parue sur le site
de l'opinion est cosignée par 120 élus
dont une dizaine des yvelines à
l'initiative de l'association génération
terrain présidé par le maire de poissy
karl olive
il demande le site de déconnecter les
élections régionales et départementales
c'est à dire de ne pas tenir les deux
scrutins le même jour pour rappel ces
élections prévues au printemps
ont été reportés en jeu en raison de la
crise sanitaire les signataires
craignent une risque un risque
d'abstention massive avec de scrutin aux
enjeux différents
elle est départementale avec des
problématiques de proximité les
régionales aux thématiques plus globale
parmi eux notamment le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine laurent brault
celui de mantes-la-jolie raphaël cognait
alexandra rosetti pour voisins le
bretonneux ou encore les conseillers
départementaux pauline vino coureur
lefebvre et jean françois raynal cette
inauguration à carrières sous poissy
l'entreprise ta l'aube et si de nouveaux
locaux n'est en 2017 au sein de la
pépinière la fabrique l'acteur de la
rénovation énergétique ils triplent sa
surface d'exploitation talo devient
ainsi le premier opérateur de la
rénovation globale au sein de la
communauté urbaine grand paris seine et
oise l'enjeu est de taille pour
l'intercommunalité dont le parc
résidentiel est le premier poste de
consommation d'énergie du territoire
devant les transports et l'industrie et
l'objectif est fixé réalisé 3 3400
rénovation énergétique parents talo
propose justement des solutions clés en
main pour les particuliers souhaitant
réaliser des travaux en ce sens en
france aujourd'hui seuls 14% des
logements affiche une bonne note
énergétique à plaisir une assemblée
citoyenne locale vient de voir le jour
elle sera composée de 60 personnes
réparties en cinq collèges différents
mondes associatifs acteurs
socio-économiques représentants des
quartiers personnes qualifiées et enfin
un dernier collège représenté par les
jeunes joséphine coleman ce berger donne
plus de détails au micro d'astrid
bergère
[Musique]
si nous semblait important c'est que
plutôt que d'aller aux deux ans des
personnes quand les projets commencés je
dirais à se structurer de façon un peu
un peu planté
c'était devenir presque en armant pour
une co-construction beaucoup plus
importante et plus là et surtout avec
une représentativité inter
générationnelle et puis dans des
secteurs complètement différent c'est
pour ça que nous avons mis en place des
collèges de réflexion et de travail pour
adhérer à ce genre d'assemblée citoyenne
il faut déjà être motivée faut avoir
envie le faire donc on appelle les
personnes à candidatures on les appelle
à faire un courrier de motivation
ce qui me semble important il faut que
cette volonté soit là après il ya des
choix qui vont être faits bien sûr par
part par la collectivité
j'espère avant le mois d'avril pour voir
faire alors une grande messe ça va être
compliqué un rassemblement de 60
personnes je pense que ça va être
complexe parce que vu la situation
sanitaire c'est ça risque d'être
difficile mais on aimerait bien pouvoir
faire quelque chose de représentatif
pour un lancement un peu officiel de
ceux de ce grand conseil citoyen c'est
en ce moment la quatrième édition des
leçons de littérature à cette occasion
le lycée jean vilar à plaisir a reçu une
écrivaine pour parler de son parcours
une rencontre enrichissante avec les
élèves reportage de célia gars de 100 go
ce sont deux classes de première du
lycée jean vilar qui ont pu écouter le
parcours d'une écrivaine ce dispositif
appelé leçon de littérature est proposée
par la région ile de france c'est la
quatrième année que celui ci y
participent
rodez élèves c'est une grande chance de
rencontrer un auteur d'écouté parcours
d'un auteur est alors j'ajouterai que
cette année c'était encore mieux encore
plus important pour les élèves en cette
période convient ou pas de cinéma
théâtre et cette année c'est l'auteur
clémentine meslois qui a partagé aux
élèves son univers ses lectures et son
travail d'écriture
c'est surtout que c'est pas un cours de
français donc j'ai beaucoup plus de
liberté que les professeurs de français
qui suivent un programme et qui sont qui
mettent des notes
là c'est surtout un échange et c'est une
parole très informel où je parle
simplement de ma façon à moi de ton
visage est mon métier
les façons vous que je le vis en fait
l'écrivaine fait partie d'un groupe de
travail qui s'appelle l'oulipo ouvroir
de littérature potentielle objectif
écrire avec des contraintes et jouer
avec les mots ce style d'écriture à
intéresser les jeunes lycéens je
connaissais pas vraiment le goût lipow
et bah j'en ai appris plus justement sur
sa sur des nouvelles manières de décrire
son idée de détourner dénombrement j'ai
trouvé ça sympathique avec les listes de
courses si ces tests est révolu comme l
inventer une vie à des personnages à
partir d' alice de course
l'auteur était à une manière
particulière d'écrire on a pu voir du
coup un livre au cdi sur les jumeaux
qu'elle faisait sur la balance est
devenu célèbre
je trouve ça intéressant de novembre
2020 à mai 2021 ce seront plus de onze
mille lycéens franciliens qui
bénéficieront de ces leçons de
littérature il mes baskets pour les
annales le nom de cette course solidaire
et interactive pour les annales y en a
c'est une jeune fille atteinte d'une
maladie génétique rare
les participants ont deux semaines pour
s'inscrire et réaliser leurs
performances chaque kilomètre parcouru
équivaut à 1 euros récoltés en faveur de
l'association au fil de léana justin
brasier une course solidaire pour
soutenir les ânes à la jeune fille de 11
ans est atteinte du syndrome cardio
faciaux cutanée une maladie génétique
principe de l'événement chacun réalise
sa performance de son côté une course
qui s'est déroulée en famille pour les
ânes à damas et des sensations qu'elle
aime vraiment courir comme ça dans la
joélette avait toujours très heureuse
d'un an fin d'été souriante elle a eu
des cris de joie c'est pour faire
avancer l'association c'est sûr c'est
bien comme ça en plus enclins monde le
fait il ya une ambiance qui règne on est
ensemble on s'entraide et puis on avance
ensemble
l'inscription se déroule sur le site pro
timing jusqu'au 6 février
pour participer à la course plusieurs
possibilités il ya 6 formats course
marche marche nordique et et course à
pied en 5 ou en 10 km c'est un euro du
kilomètre ils le font voilà
chacun de leur côté ça permet de pouvoir
le faire ou qu'on soit en france ou sur
sur le monde et une fois qu'on a fini
l'autre course en fait on renseigne
directement sa performance sur sur le
site
léana à participer à la course en
joëlette la famille à travailler en
équipe et c'est relayé pour courir à lée
10 km une course réalisée en 1h10
sachant qu'on a marché on a fait des
échanges pour la joëlette donc on est
content de temps ont changé il y avait
un pompier qui était venue pour un petit
peu gêné et on avait pris un vélo pour
tourner au chili on est un petit peu et
puis j'ai des moments
objectif de cette course virtuelle
récolter des fonds pour l'association au
fil de léana un budget pour financer des
équipements pour enfants porteurs de
handicap et acquérir un vélo cargo pour
les ana pour qu'on puisse partir en vtt
avec ses frères est ce un vélo dans
lequel en fait on peut la soir et un
soir également son chien avec elle et ça
nous permet voilà d'être autonome et de
pouvoir partir dans les champs en
famille pour l'heure près de 400
personnes se sont déjà inscrites à
l'événement
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi demain vendredi vous
retrouverez eléonore sinoquet et célia
gars de son go pour le 7-8 week-end les
missions de la rédaction pour bien
terminer la semaine au gré de
l'actualité et 10 des loisirs très belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]